et alors aujourd'hui on va traiter d'un
sujet intéressant un sujet auquel
beaucoup de tubes heures s'intéresse à
savoir comment trouver sa propre musique
sur youtube comment m samedi pour par un
problème de monétisation il faut pouvoir
effectivement faire des vidéos qui
fonctionne qui peuvent être monétisée
alors je vais t'expliquer assez
rapidement comment ça marche
et tu vas voir c'est pas très compliqué
il ya quelques astuces à connaître et
donc on va parler de musique aujourd'hui
en réalité il ya trois points importants
à connaître le tout premier point c'est
la bibliothèque gratuite b you tube qui
fonctionne plutôt pas mal le deuxième
fois c'est la société indépendante tu
payes un petit forfait
je vais te montrer dans quelques
instants et tu vas voir qu'avec ça tu
peux avoir accès à plein de musique et
le troisième point c'est celui que
j'utilise ou en tout cas pour l'instant
c'est de faire ta musique toi ben avec
des logiciels gratuits en trois quatre
cinq minutes maximum
tu as un morceau que tu peut réutiliser
et tu vas voir c'est top
le tout premier point c'est d'utiliser
la bibliothèque de musique gratuite de
youtube qui est quand même plutôt pas
mal on m'a acheté un petit coup d'oeil à
léviathan up
alors allons voir ce que tu veux c'est
que tu penses à ton créateur studio et
une fois que tu es dessus tu va naviguer
jusqu'à bon je crois que c'est créer tu
vas sur l'onglet créé tu as musique
gratuite effets sonores et ce à trois
mois c'est plutôt pas mal
tu peux choisir un tu mettais musique tu
les écoutes et tu peux les intégrer
directement ses des musiques libres de
droit si tu veux
après le problème c'est qu exane
allemand tout le monde aura la même
musique parce qu'il en a pas tant que ça
au final
ainsi il y en a quand même quelques unes
bon bah voilà tu peux t'amuser tu peux
aller jeter un coup d'oeil non mais tu
fuck sont pas mal c'est quand même
plutôt pas mal produit et au final
oh oh oh oh tu vas voir là dessus il ya
quand même pas mal de choses ça c'est
tout premier point
le deuxième point c'est d'utiliser des
sites il ya différence équipe on propose
effectivement de la musique contre un
petit forfait mensuel moyen en a que je
trouve plutôt pas mal et que
effectivement j'ai pas encore utilisé
mais que tu peux aller voir d'autant
plus qu'il ya 30 jours d'essai gratuit
donc ça veut ça serait con de s'en
priver
c'est un site qui s'appelle épidémique
sand épidémique sans point comme je te
mettrai le lien dans la description tu
pourras aller voir c'est un site où tu
vas effectivement avoir plein plein
plein plein de musiques directement pour
youtube que tu vas pouvoir utiliser
autant que tu veux tu as trois types
d'abonnement ainsi sur l'appui des mix
entre c'est vraiment pas mal et c'est
pas très cher en réalité le tout premier
c'est le starter et pour 13 euros par
mois tu vas avoir accès si tu veux à
l'ensemble de leur catalogue
la seule contrainte c'est que tu dois
faire pas plus de 500000 vues par mois
donc mon 7 starter honnêtement cette
année cinq cent mille vues par mois
c'est déjà pas mal ça permet de voir
venir
après un tout petit peu plus cher
jusqu'à 5 millions de vues par mois
tu as le professionnel pour 25 27 euros
honnêtement c'est pas des colons et
ensuite aller pique les pics et pour les
grandes chaînes
c'est au dessus de 5 millions de vues
par mois
tu payes 125 euros est taxé à tous
catalogue en illimité c'est top
l'intérêt d'un truc comme épidémiques
sont sais que tu vas avoir accès à un
catalogue démentiel avec plein de
musique de qualité pro d'ambiances
différentes choisies tu navigues voilà
tu veux tellement bien ou tel site elle
s'attelle musique tu as accès à tous et
c'est génial
alors ça ce sont les abonnements pour
youtube il ya des abonnements après si
tu fais des vidéos si tu fais des choses
en dehors de youtube
par contre c'est 99 centimes d'euro la
seconde donc si tu veux tout de suite de
faire une vidéo
c'est extrêmement cher par contre pour
youtube et les forfaits qui sont
vraiment sympas pas très cher je te lis
tu peux faire un essai gratuit de 30
jours
ça serait content privée d'autant plus
que si tu payes tu prennes abonnement
parents ta 20% de remise donc au final
c'est tout bénef c'est vraiment
intéressant tout en sachant que ce qui
est super intéressant c'est que si tu
prends un abonnement d'un mois
tu fais plein de vidéos pendant un mois
et que tu vas dispatchés sur plusieurs
semaines toutes les vidéos qui ont été
faites quant à un abonnement chez eux
eh ben tu peux continuer à les utiliser
d'habitude à plus d'abonnement chez eux
donc c'est tout bénef c'est pas très
cher et c'est pas mal mais ça reste
payant si tu veux pas payer il ya une
troisième solution c'est une solution
que moi j'utilise un petit logiciel
directement sur mon iphone tu
probablement aussi sous android 1
vérifier et qui est gratuit sur tout et
qui permet de faire ta musique toi même
extrêmement facilement via le site
montre et on s'entend d'iphone qui font
que tu fasses il faut que tu utilise le
logiciel qui s'appelle figure tu vas
dessus directement et dans figure tu
peux faire plein de choses alors je te
montre ça c'est un peu les morceaux que
j'ai créée donc on va dedans il ya de
tout un tas vraiment de tout et tous les
morceaux que tu as pu entendre dans
toutes mes différentes vidéos et tout a
été créé et est dans ce qu'on va faire
si je vais expliquer comment ça marche
on va prendre le départ d'un nouveau
morceau je vais dans global donc je me
mets en 123 c'est très bien ça me va on
va se mettre plus tôt un petit voilà un
petit majeur tac tac tac mix je veux
mais en huit bars 8 bars pattern jeu
mais choisit une robe
surtout qu'un petit peu avec troll aller
comme ça et j'enregistre jeu mirek déjà
s'appuyer
sam est le métronome ça me calme le
metrodome s'arranger si tu veux tu vois
ça me fait mon break directement dans
mon appli je regarde en haut j'ai
d'avoir défilement et je vois quand
j'arrive à la fin je suis arrivé à la
fin ensuite je parle bel avec et ensuite
j'ai maintenant mon charleston mon ex je
veux mettre un peu plus rapide tu vois
je me tape sur cale en double attention
je mets rec j'appuie sur la terre battue
de faire varier du balaton doigt dessus
savary un petit peu directement ces
temps que ça arrive à la fin ça ne
t'aimons pas terme de base voilà on y
est allés ça marche mais trois semaines
des tomes
n'importe quoi
ok donc là on enregistrait ça qu'on peut
mettre une caisse claire si on veut
aller peu importe le temps et sur la
basse tiens je suis très bien ça on s'en
fout de façon directe on enregistre
voilà le ton en bout par est et tu vois
ce accueilli en boucle alors que tu peux
changer les paramètres avec lori ça bon
matelas très amusé tu vas découvrir sa
super gîte le lead c'est un peu kitsch
moussa il ya plein effet du baladin sur
une petite route le peuple un truc on va
mettre ça on va faire sa part en prime
16 on essaye là dessus attention on
arrête on va enregistrer 3,4
[Musique]
je vais la liste pour dessus et voilà
et si un bouclage un petit morceau qui
tourne bon c'est tout courant nettement
aux citoyens et aux x je peux modifier
directement si tu veux le son de la
batterie ils sont manas leçon de le
délai a ajouté de la red army sur les
choses comme ça pourquoi montrer soit un
peu plus cool du un peu changé le son
[Musique]
tu entends en temps réel un sapin de
fuite
c'est génial attend vraiment le truc à
un peu à deux balles là mais on peut
rendre la dass un peu plus méchant tu
[Musique]
peux faire ce que tu veux une fête pour
morceau qu'est là si tu veux tu vas
ensuite dans les songes tu vas lui donne
un nom en payant son petit crayon on va
l'appeler par exemple qu'aucun un lapin
ça sera une demande de me la musique ou
que l'on lapin je termine je fais save
et ensuite ce que je me fais j'ai
sauvegardé comme ça et quand je vais
dans mes musiques as tu vois tout en bas
si beaucoup mon lapin et si par exemple
je me dis que sur ce morceau là par
exemple la structure open je veux garder
que la base par exemple et la batterie
pour faire un petit pattern quand je
parle
eh ben je vais dans mx je mets en
moumoute le lead et hop
et ça me fait un petit pas terme de base
tu vois et là je clique sur mon stylo je
me mets un petit truc pour me dire
qu'ils appellent le line up without
lille terminé saved by the balance et du
coup j'ai deux salles morceaux toi tu
peux le faire tu peux virer la battre
veux dire et la batterie tu peux laisser
que la batterie tu peux c'est que le
litre à te fais ce que tu veux et tu
compenses tom hanks autour de ça donc
c'est super intéressant
ensuite ce que tu fais c'est que tu vas
directement sur la petite flèche la
petite porte qui a emballé ici claque
d'appui et tu choisis tu peux l'envoyer
directement sur son code sera est une
structure itunes ce qui fait que ça me
va directement sans manquer mon itunes
je branche mon téléphone l'a directement
dedans je vais dans itunes chauffer dans
mon iphone je vais dans mon itunes
je regarde dans l'application et dans
l'application je peux récupérer
directement métier dedans et c'est au
final juste extraordinaire ce qui me
permet au final si tu veux d'avoir
autant de morceaux que je veux pour
fabriquer des morceaux au rythme que je
veux comme je veux sans emmerder et au
final de pouvoir l'utiliser pour mes
vidéos d'avoir aucun problème de droits
d'auteur et d'avoir de la musique que
personne n'a nulle part avec au final
une application qui est
intuit donc voila c'était mes trois
points importants si tu veux qu'on
pouvoir avoir de la musique gratuite
directement pour thème une vidéo youtube
tu verras après y'a pas d'autres
solutions qui existent donc tu peux
aller naviguer droite à gauche on fait
de bons plans il ya plein plein plein
plein de solutions
moi je fais comme ça j'utilise figure je
compose mes morceaux en ce moment
j'entends un petit peu moins je recycle
un peu mais il ya quelque chose que je
faisais je composais un morceau par
vidéo ce qui fait que chaque vidéo peut
avoir sa propre atmosphère sa propre
musique tu l'utilisent comme tu veux et
tu te mets des patterns sous ta voix si
tu le souhaites tu fais vraiment comme
tu veux c'est juste top
dis-moi ce que tu en penses 10 moto ce
que tu utilises comme musique pour tes
vidéos mais mon commentaire
dis moi signe qui conseille te plaise
n'hésite pas à regarder cette vidéo
l'acquis aussi très sympa abonne toi ma
chaise je te remercie mon lapin et je te
dis à très bientôt pour de nouvelles
vidéos
ciao